[音楽]
これは私が5歳の時の写真です
右から2番目です
私はいつもこれ仲良し四人組の写真のようにこう言って持ってきたんですが実はそう
じゃなくて
小さいとき実は友達づくりが大の苦手だったんですね
だからいつも一人でを書いていました
でもそんな私が今日皆さんに人とつながるについての話をします
この文字にも書いている通り私は幼いころ手先が非常に今日だった
ということで今建築家としての仕事をしています
でまず今日は皆さんに私が開き設計をした2つのある建築についてのお話を皆さんにお
伝えしたいと思います
その建築2つにはある共通点があるのでそちらをちょっと意識して聞いてください
はいまず1つめの設計ですこちらは音楽家のために作られた専用の集合住宅いわゆる
音楽家専用マンションです
これは今からかれこれ僕が15年くらい前の
まぁ結局私まだか汚し駆け出しの頃の仕事です
コンセプトは音と共に暮らす音楽の中にある生活です
なので楽器の音が外に漏れないという非常に高度な防音性能が必要となりました
でもね皆さんね想像していただきたいんですけど
防錆のといってもたとえば録音室とかまあそういう防音室みたいなところで生活をする
ということ
出来ませんね実際のところ
なので私はこのボーンというものは優れた技術に頼ることとしてもう一つ大事な音と共
に生活をするというコンセプトをどのようにすれば実現できるのかっていうことを一生
懸命考えたんですね
で考えて考え抜いて一つひらめいたんですそれは
ホンレイ住宅とする1部屋を10人の人が自由に使えるフリールームとして開放する
ことだったんです
このフリールームこれは住んでる人が自由に使えるということつまり音楽家が住んで
いるので自由に音を奏でる
例えばコンサートをしたりいわば中に音を表現するそして音を共有する空間となります
だけど先ほど言いましたボーンは技術に頼ったためにいざ
このマンションに音楽家がたくさん進み出すとわずかな音も0でもトラブルになるん
じゃないのかなという不安がすごくかられたんですね
すごくファンが大きくくらいましただけど実際このフリールームがその不安を打ち消し
てくれたんです
ん
ますちょっと長所があるんですよっていうのも実はこのフリールームの存在が実は住人
同士のコミュニティを構築したんですでこのコミュニティが構築すると面白くなってき
たのはそのコミュニティを構築すると住んでる人以外の音楽家がどんどんで集まってき
てそこでサロン
運行さあとしてそのサロンコンサートを聴きに地域の人が集まってきたんですね
でここまで来るともうマンションと域を越えて一つの音楽の広場
音のたまり場という形になったんです
この音の広場が新しい価値を生み出すっていうのはこの音の広場が実はボーンの作用と
なったんです
音の広場これちょっと皆さん身近な例でねちょっとイメージをしていただきたいんです
けども
例えばそのマンションに住んでますで
上の会の人の足音がドタバタするようなそういう生活音がありますよね
それが気になるかならないかというのは上の人と交流があるかないかでその感じ方が
大きく変わってきますよねそれとまったく同じなんですね
つまりその交流によって生まれたそのコミュニティが実は技術にも勝る
防音の効果とし
最大に発表してくれたんです
その結果をと共に暮らす
音楽の中にある生活というコンセプトを見事に実現をしてくれたそういう建物です次
いきます
はいこちらは
駅前再開発の設計です私にとってはすごくチャレンジとなった大きな仕事でした
これはここからチェック柄近所ですね阪急箕面の駅というところで
阪急の妙には箕面滝というところがあるその観光地にいいかれるためのまあ入り口と
なる駅です
でも開発前のこの駅前はまあ観光客にとってはまあ観光地に行くための単なる通貨銅銭
となっていたために例えばこの駅周辺で買い物をしたりそういう高
経済効果が生まれにくいということが書かれてから課題としてあったんですね
でそこで持ち上がったのがその観光客の流れに変化をもたらそうというそういう歳回数
が持ち上がったんです
で
こちら開発前なんですがこのように開発前の駅前を見ると観光客が帰って帰ってきます
そうするとポリ見えるのが改札口なんですね改札口が直視できるっていう事なので観光
客は迷いなくこの駅の中に帰っていったんです
最初の再開発は
こんなんだったんですもう入らないように壁を設けてしまうと
壁を作るんですここにはいそういう案があったんです
私ではないですがでそれを聞いたときにね確かに火病も受けることは人の流れを変え
たり会社特注名なくするという意味ではある一定の効果が合うと思います
だけど
帰って閉塞感を生んだり先が見えなくなるという不安感というものを見ます
そして何よりここに壁ができることで本当に景観的に美しいのかなっていうすごく
大きな
その不安というか疑問に駆られたんですね
で私考えたんですね
先ほど申しました150万人が集まるような非常に大きな駅
いわば人が集まる力を呼ぶべきなんですね
だったらその人の力で人の動きを変えることができないかなと
もっと言うとパン公格の力で観光客の動きを変えてしまうことができないかということ
を考えたんです
これもまたちょっと皆さん身近な例でちょっとイメージをしていただきます
例えばこの細い廊下がありますよね細い廊下に
まあ先輩同士とか上司の人同士がお話をしているところに通しもそこを通りぬけないと
いけないし
皆さんどうされますか僕だったら来てくるようにあるんですねこれやると皆さん1回
ふらっとやったことあると思うんですこれは何かという
と人と人とが作る見えない壁皆さん感じられてるんですよ
その見えない壁をくぐり抜ける避けて避けて通るという
これは人間の自然な行動なんですねで私はそれをこのまあ改札口と
港観光客が帰ってくるこの間の部分に
岡部として作ることができないかって考えたんですここに人の影ができる人のたまりを
作れば
いいのじゃないかと考えたんですね
観光客が集まる府観光地の入り口となっている役なので
例えば観光客が観光地の所調べ物をしたりとか
まあお話をしたり休憩もしたりとそういう風に言うをたくさんですね
こうまあ観光客のこの行動というのはものすごく強くイメージしたんです
たくさんたくさんイメージしてそしてまたひらめいたんです
ねそれがこちらですねベンチです
この電池が人のたまりをつくって人の溜まりになればそれが人の壁になる
なるんじゃないのかなとその人の壁を交わすように通ると観光客の流れは変わるのでは
ないかとひらめいたんですね
はい実際に効果はてきめんに現れました
このベンチを中心に人の溜まりができてその人の溜まりが本当に人の壁となって
でその人の壁を交わすように観光客は
駅周辺の散策へとつながって動いていったんです
面白いのはたった数脚のベンチを置いてるだけなんです
でもたった集客のベンチが本来
知らない人同士150万円そうですほぼ知らない人同士がいるんですけども
観光っていう共通の目的を持った人同士のコミュニケーションを本当に滑らかにして
でまぁ気軽に
一安くしてくれたんですねでまた造形的にも
まあ人が作る非常に躍動感のある流動的な美しい
壁が出来上がったんです
結果
駅俊英の散策へとつながったので当然周りが活気に潤い
にぎわいができてそして何よりこの新しい今までなかった目のオネエ系の景観という
ものを作り上げることができました
はいで今二つの私建築の話をしたんですが共通点
あのもう勘のいい人はもうお気づきだと思うんですねはいフィンとはフリールームで
ありそしてベンチですつまり何かというと人と人とつながるですね人と人とのつながり
を生み出す場所となっているんです
ます
私は正賢知紘通して人と人とのつながりをが生み出すその力というものを学んだんです
けれども
一方ねじゃあ私が生身の人間です人とどのように私自身がつながっていってるのか
つながっていったらいいのかということを常に考えてきました
なぜかというと冒頭でいいました私
友達づくりが大の苦手だったんですそれがずっと頭にこびりついてるんで
常に今でも考えていますで今からするお話は建築ではありません
ある男性ですその男性今から10年くらい前であった
その男性とのつながりどのように出会ってどのようにつながっていったのかという
プロセスについてのお話をします
仮にその人アルファベットの a さんと呼ぶことにします a さんです
初めて a さんと会った時はもちろん挨拶をしただけでした
でもなんかね家に帰るとすごく印象に残るような人だったんですね
でその後にその a さんの仕事を少し手伝う
そういう機会ができたんですっていうことはその a さんとその後
まあたくさん接するまあ回数が増えたんですねでっ
接すれば接するほどその a さんの魅力に惹かれて
でこの人と友達になりたいななんかくなりたいなというそういう強い気持ちに駆られた
んです
でも実際ねその気持ちに駆られるのはいいんですけども
じゃあどうやったらその人と仲良くなれるのかなどうやったらその人と友達になれるの
かな
なかなか言い方って見つからないですよねなかなか
吸った見つからないと思います
で私はちょっとねひらめきじゃないですまた考えたんです
もう a さんとね一対一でこれで直接制するってことをちょっとやめて別の形で
接するある作戦を考えたんですねこれ誰かというと
a 3直接私がつながるのではなくて a さんと同じようにつながりたい b さん
c さんを a さんにつなげるというそういう作戦に出たんです
なんで繋げるのかというと
自分がつながりたい人同士なのでそういう魅力ある人同士をつなげるとピットすごい
化学反応
凄いことが起きるんじゃないのかなというイメージがイメージです
だけど明確にできたんですね
でそのまあイメージ
まあするは中でですねまぁちょっとオーバーに言うと坂本龍馬が薩摩と長州をつないだ
よな
そういったイメージがどこかには頭にこびりつきながら実は a さんにたくさん
いろんな人を紹介していきました色々つないでいったんですねその時私は主役ではない
です
あくまでも裏方主役は紹介する b 3 c 3 d 3 e さんなんです
まあいわば演出家気取りでそういうことをやってたんですが
面白いことに
a さんにいろんな人をつないでいくとね実は私の取り巻く環境が大きく動き出したん
です
私自身の環境が
先ほど話で駅前再開発の仕事これも実は a さんとのつながりで得たものなんです
でもっと面白いのはその a さん自身にちょっと仕事で重要な場面が出てきたんです
ねでその場面でまぁ今まで支えてきた
b 3 c 3 t see her 方と一つのチームになって
その仕事を一緒にすることができたんです
結果大きな成果を生むことになったんですねこれは私が a さんで初めて出会った時
にあ
夢に描いていた舞台が現実になったそういう瞬間だったんです
a さんに人をつなぐことでおける作業で言ったその化学反応ですね
その化学反応っていうのは人の数つないだ数の人の分だけその化学反応ておきます
ってね面白いのは a さんにいろんな人をつないでいくわけですから
ビックリするぐらいの価格版が起きてるわけなんです自分が消化できないくらいでも
ふっと気付くと
a さんと深く繋がってたんですね気付いたって感じです
私がつながり言ってるんじゃないんですねふと化学反応によってつながっていたんです
ね
でまぁ人と深く繋がるって言うところのイメージなんですが私は建築やってるのでどう
しても立体的な話をするんですが
こととものだけじゃなくて人にも必ずこういう事故があるということです
それとその軸には必ずこのように奥行きがあるっていうこと
これを人付き合いでも必ず強くイメージ渡ししています
例えば先ほどの a さんと私が出会った頃
まあ仲良くなりたいなぁと思っている状態というまさしくこの xy の軸のこの平面
的な薄っぺら状態なんです後ろにまだ何もないのでだけどその後に私は先ほど言いまし
た作戦を変えたので b 3 c 3 d 3 e 3といろんな人をつないでいった
いろんなひとつねで
ことで化学反応ってものはたくさん起きたとこれがこのように後ろにフィルターのよう
に重なっていくようなイメージなんです
そうするとこの a さんが薄っぺらくして見えてなかったものがいつのまにか立体的
に奥行きのある者として見え方が変わってくるんです
この
a さんにつないで起きたこの素敵なことこの化学反応は z軸のこのような
フィルターなので
そのフィルターの数が多ければ多いほどより鮮明にクリアねえさんが見えてきますし
っていうことはこの数を増やすということは人をたくさんつなげていくということです
よね
分かりやすくいうとつまり深く繋がるということはこの奥行きを
作ることだということなんです
私はこうしたことからですね
素敵なこととかものを生み出したいそしてそれを実現したい時の最も有効的な方法は人
と人とをつなげることだっていうことを確信を得たんですね
先ほどの音楽家山をマンションでも
ボーンを技術だけで解決するという考え方はまたしこの x y 軸のペラペラな状態
です
だけどそこに私はフリールームという z軸を足しました
駅前再開発も全く同じです
人の流れを壁をつくって解決するという考え方これは x y 軸の考え方としてそこ
にベンチという z 二交代したわけなんです
そうすると z軸を足すことで人と人とのつながりが生み出すその力によって人の流れ
とか
防音っていうそういう本来の課題の解決につながったわ
ナンデスで私はここで建築的な同時に奥行きも知ることになったんですね
これは実は人と人とのつながりは全く一緒で
ヨナが表面的な上っ面な付き合っておくいうのは私9最初に
一枚の状態なんですだけど世の中
素晴らしい事や物にはこうなんていうから上っ面じゃない
奥行きがあるからこそ人の人々の感動って言うのよものなんですね
で私は思うんです人と人とをつなげることでその奥行きっていうの出来上がります
そしてどんどんつなげていくとその送りピットはどんどん深さが増していくんです
そうすると自分の取り巻く環境がですね
自分の想像を遥かに絶することとして起こるんです確実残ります
そうすると人間って火事場のクソ力でそのことに対応しようとして頑張りますこれが
チャンスなんです
でそのチャンスをちゃんと活かして成長した人はどうなるかというと
今度は誰かに
人を繋げられるんです自分の今度つなげられる場になって自分がフィルターとなって
いずれはやってくるんですそうなった時初めて関わった所つながった人みんなが本当に
ハッピーで幸せな状態になれるそういうふうに思うんです
私は幼い頃
友達づくりが大の苦手でだけどもこれらの経験を通して人と人とのつながりが生み出す
この奥行きというものこの魔法に気づいたんですよ
人と人とつなげるそういうきっかけとなることって誰にもできます
私が今ここに立って皆さんとつながるきっかけを得たことも実は人と人とつなげること
から始まっているんです
難しく考える人はないんですね身近な人でいいので身近な人にまずは人をつなげる
つなげてあげるそういったことからまず始めるとピット
自分の将来は想像を絶する遥かに絶することが絶対に起こってやっていきます
素敵なつながりとは
人をつなげること
ありがとうございました